we're going to begin with charlie
dagetta he is in keeve a city that has
been heavily fortified as the fight
rages on just outside that city charlie
many of the images that you're bringing
to us are also showing up on the phones
of the people here coming over the
border good morning
good morning to you tony yeah it's tough
to watch a number of cease-fires have
been declared in some of the hardest hit
cities like mariopol and harkeev but
they are shaky at best and it has been
another brutal night for civilians here
we have to warn viewers that some might
find these images disturbing
emergency teams picked through the
rubble of another apartment building
flattened by russian airstrikes
overnight in a harrowing search for
survivors
finding instead lifeless bodies families
a couple of children officials in the
city of sumi in northeast ukraine say at
least 21 people were killed
adding to the atrocities and growing
death toll in the russian military's
seemingly reckless and random shelling
and aerial bombardment of residential
areas
ukrainian forces are holding ground
where they can
continuing to mount a fierce resistance
yet russian forces continue to advance
to the outskirts of the capital itself
and residents are digging in determined
to defend the city
some make molotov cocktails 25 year old
stanislav would rather be drumming in
his rock band but duty beckons why was
it important for you to volunteer to
volunteer because
i want to be a drummer i want to be i
want to have my
country free and i just want to live my
life
this maternity hospital in kiev has
become a makeshift bomb shelter for
heavily pregnant mothers
there's a reason they're taking shelter
in the hallways in the basement of this
hospital it's just
simply too dangerous what should be one
of the most magical moments for new
parents has also been one of the most
terrifying
congratulations thank you it's a fresh
one a fresh one
is this your first child yep
suleimia and max welcomed their son
hivniyak into a world of air raid sirens
and explosions i don't
know
my emotions so mixed
because the first time i can hope
this is your first time yes i was laying
all night because
the delivery was not easy
what does it feel like to hold your son
i can i cannot explain it
it is the most happy moment in my life
the couple live on the top floor of a
nine-story apartment building here in
the capitol they told us they don't know
when or even if they'll ever take their
baby boy back home
tony
charlie daggett heartbreaking scenes
there of what so many are fleeing from
if they can others cannot